and gone out of our way to try to find the very best people we can,
mostly fail to get the best out of them.
So how do we develop the skills that we need?
Because it does take skill and practice, too.
If we aren't going to be afraid of conflict,
we have to see it as thinking,
and then we have to get really good at it.
So, recently, I worked with an executive named Joe,
and Joe worked for a medical device company.
And Joe was very worried about the device that he was working on.
He thought that it was too complicated
and he thought that its complexity
created margins of error that could really hurt people.
He was afraid of doing damage to the patients he was trying to help.
But when he looked around his organization,
nobody else seemed to be at all worried.
So, he didn't really want to say anything.
After all, maybe they knew something he didn't.
Maybe he'd look stupid.
But he kept worrying about it,
and he worried about it so much that he got to the point
where he thought the only thing he could do
was leave a job he loved.
In the end, Joe and I found a way
for him to raise his concerns.
And what happened then is what almost always
happens in this situation.
It turned out everybody had exactly the same
questions and doubts.
So now Joe had allies. They could think together.
And yes, there was a lot of conflict and debate
and argument, but that allowed everyone around the table
to be creative, to solve the problem,
and to change the device.
Joe was what a lot of people might think of
as a whistle-blower,
except that like almost all whistle-blowers,
he wasn't a crank at all,
he was passionately devoted to the organization
and the higher purposes that that organization served.
But he had been so afraid of conflict,
until finally he became more afraid of the silence.
And when he dared to speak,
he discovered much more inside himself
and much more give in the system than he had ever imagined.
And his colleagues don't think of him as a crank.
They think of him as a leader.
So, how do we have these conversations more easily
and more often?
Well, the University of Delft
requires that its PhD students
have to submit five statements that they're prepared to defend.
It doesn't really matter what the statements are about,
what matters is that the candidates are willing and able
to stand up to authority.
I think it's a fantastic system,
but I think leaving it to PhD candidates
is far too few people, and way too late in life.
I think we need to be teaching these skills
to kids and adults at every stage of their development,
if we want to have thinking organizations
and a thinking society.
The fact is that most of the biggest catastrophes that we've witnessed
rarely come from information that is secret or hidden.
It comes from information that is freely available and out there,
but that we are willfully blind to,
because we can't handle, don't want to handle,
the conflict that it provokes.
But when we dare to break that silence,
or when we dare to see,
and we create conflict,
we enable ourselves and the people around us
to do our very best thinking.
Open information is fantastic,
open networks are essential.
But the truth won't set us free
until we develop the skills and the habit and the talent
and the moral courage to use it.
Openness isn't the end.
It's the beginning.
(Applause)